tonight's the night when many people
toast the new year with champagne or
something stronger and sometimes with
regrets the following day but in Japan
it's not over indulgence that's
concerning the government it's people
swearing off alcohol and the economic
side effect that it's having Lucy Craft
has a story from Tokyo
it's one of the hottest new trends in
Japan bars without booze raising glasses
of non-alcoholic wine these Millennials
say they do enjoy the real thing but
only on special occasions
the student said I'm not worried about
my health but I'd rather spend the money
on nice meals
non-alcohol bars like this one are
starting to take off in Japan popular
especially among younger Japanese and
that's giving the national government a
hangover
with tax revenue from alcoholic
beverages drying up down 30 percent in
recent decades the government launched a
widely mocked campaign seeking ideas on
how to get young Japanese drinking again
the so-called sober curious movement has
stunned officials here where much of
life revolves around drinking
during occasions like cherry blossom
viewing
office drinking parties have long been
considered essential to company team
building the most recent survey from
2016 found Tokyo alone packed with
nearly thirty thousand bars and pubs
with over 90 percent of young Japanese
reporting they drink rarely or not at
all even beer Behemoth Asahi has opened
a bar catering to the alcohol averse
nowadays naan or low alcohol beer and
liquor is where the growth is
bartender susamo Sakurai serves an
underserved Market teetotalers of all
ages thirsting for a local pub without
the liquor governments drink more
campaign he said is tone deaf I think
it's a terrible idea he said it's like
trying to get people to smoke more Japan
is a group oriented Society where
getting along has often meant going
along with drinking
consequences visible on trains and city
streets he said Japan has a long
tradition of bonding over alcohol but
people are starting to wise up for CBS
Saturday morning Lucy Craft Tokyo
I mean you see people saying don't over
drink be careful all the time that's the
first time I've seen something like this
where they're like listen start drinking
me too
I'm going to say yeah that's there's not
much a lot more to say we'll leave it to
moderation that's a good idea